hello everyone and welcome to another
very impressive game from round three of
this year's London chess classic it is
Michael Adams versus MOS Bartel Adams
doing really great in the tournament he
had a win against tabat taba in round
one and Mos lost to Gish in round one so
Adams would of course like to continue
his run and MOS would like to bounce
back with a win H but it's not going to
be easy as even though there are of
similar rating here 2661 to 2659 Adams
uh some some long long time ago was
actually uh a full 100 points high rated
his top rating was
2761 and he currently at 52 years of age
he played against pretty much everyone
that mattered in the Chess World
throughout this period uh to give you an
example um against former world champion
Anatoli karpov he played several times
he defeated him once even he has two
draws and uh quite a few draws six draws
against carpov against vishan Anand he
has six wins 18 Los losses and 37 draws
only against former world champion G
Kasparov uh he does not have a single
win he faced him 18 times but even out
of those 18 times he was able to draw
Kasparov eight times but then you know
uh take it some decade after those games
uh he faced for example Magnus Carlson
in 2010 Olympiad he defeated Magnus
Carlson in 20 2010 Magnus Carlson was
very very strong player also he defeated
Fabiano corana in Dortmund in 2013 so
you know doesn't matter when he plays he
just doesn't seem to age chess wise and
he's playing against M Bartel like I
said polish grandmas four times a Polish
Champion also represented Poland many
times in the Olympiad so uh two strong
players brawling it out let's see what
happens so Adams has the white pieces
and he opens with Pawn to E4 uh we have
Pawn to C6 going for the caroan defense
and now Pawn to D4 we have D5 Knight to
C3 and now we have um uh sorry uh Pawn
to E5 he did not go for Knight C3 he
went for the advanced variation for Pawn
to E5 and now Bishop to F5 and here I
always say that you could go for the
bayonet attack with G4 and if you face
the bishop to F5 move quite quite a lot
of times maybe in your online games
maybe you can explore this uh it's a
very creative idea uh for example let's
say play F4 black will play F6 you can
even go H5 and you can really go after
that bishop and once black stops you
trapping it you can even play F5 and
sort of trap the bishop this way making
it useless uh but okay black will have
some F4 ideas himself maybe later on to
free up the bishop it's possible uh you
know if you if you if you struggle with
the bishop to F5 line maybe try try it
out but Knight to F3 uh is the classical
way that of course we we will see here
Bishop to E2 uh sorry Pawn to E6 Bishop
to E2 and now Knight to D7 we have
castles and now Pawn to A5 stopping Pawn
to B4 also getting ready for further
expansion on the queen side Pawn to A4
stopping B5 and now Pawn to F6 of course
you want to break white strong Center
here uh Bishop to E3 and now there are a
couple of games that reach this position
for example F captures on E5 is a know
move Queen to C7 is a know move but here
we have Queen to B6 uh by m and it is
now as of move eight that we have a
completely new game so it's a pretty
standard maneuver that you will see
putting pressure on the center this will
help support C5 also you're putting
pressure on B2 uh what can you do here
well Adams Place some something that uh
that looks like something I would play
in a bullet game and blunder two of my
pawns that's exactly what it looks like
Knight to D2 and it looks like uh you
can just capture on B2 and then on C2 so
what's what's the real idea here why is
he offering this Pawn well uh capturing
on B2 with the queen is actually the top
move recommended by the engine but it's
such a such an ugly position for black
to face especially if you if this is a
preparation I don't know if this is a
preparation or if Michael uh came up
with this over the board but the idea is
that after captures there's night 1 uh
defending the pawn and now you will go
after the black queen so the black queen
should Escape now you bring the Knight
to D3 and after black develops but it's
not easy for black to develop how do you
how do you develop the bishop the Knight
get the Rook into the game let's say you
try something like this you want to go
for the standard G6 Square already e
captures on F6 happens and if Knight
captures on F6 the Knight finds a
beautiful outpost on E5 and again black
will struggle with development for
example Knight to G6 there's already G4
trapping the bishop there's not nothing
you can do here with Bishop E4 you
attack the queen and once the queen
moves F3 again traps the bishop uh so a
very very tricky idea this Knight B to
d2 move so MOS decides against this he
plays F captures on E5 Knight captures
Knight captures e d captures on E5 and
now he goes for Bishop to C5 again
capturing on B2 Rook to B1 then the
queen has to capture on C2 everything
gets traded off here you will see Rook
captures on B7 Bishop captures on A4 and
it seems like black is up to pawn so why
not go for this well the problem is how
do you develop your king side for
example Knight F3 what do you play
because I'm like Knight E7 Knight G5 and
already black is uh black resigns this
there's no good move here so after d
captures on E5 Bishop to C5 was played
and now Bishop captures on C5 Queen
captures on C5 and now Knight to B3
attacking the queen and again uh
offering some material here but if you
go for it now let's say queen captures
and C2 Queen captures and Bishop
captures then Knight to D4 attacks the
bishop and the E6 pawn and if you want
to defend it you just kick it away
further and after Bishop G6 you capture
on E6 and now it's uh again much much
better for white you're going after this
check here and also you're attacking the
G7 Pawn if you defended then you can
just move away let's say check King E7
now we play F4 H then you play F5 and
again white gets a winning position out
of this so after Knight B3 Queen back to
E7 was played and now Bishop to H5 with
check forcing um
M to to play Pawn to G6 because if you
play Bishop G6 then you can just capture
and M A Black's Pawn structure so G6 and
now Bishop back to E2 and now Pawn to H5
stopping any G4 ideas and it seems that
black survived this and is back into the
game uh but the question is how do you
develop the Knight and also how good is
this light Square Bishop with all of the
pawns and light squares so Queen to D2
now it's time to grab hold of the dark
squares and queen to
C7 uh of course you have to defend the
A5 pawn queen to D2 also put pressure on
that A5 pawn bishop to D3 offering a
trade and now Knight to H6 trying to get
the Knight into the game Knight to D4
and now we have Queen to E7 uh we have
Rook to A3 bringing uh the very strong
piece into the game Rook can come then
to B3 put pressure on B7 now comes
Bishop captures Rook captures on D3 and
now Knight to F5 so it seems M solved
all of his developing problems Knight
captures G Capt and now Pawn to C4 so is
he in any trouble here well let's see
King to F7 you have to connect Rook
somehow and now C captures on D5 e
captures and Rook to E1 preparing Pawn
to E6 now for those of you who are you
know maybe approaching chess in the in
the spirit of the great mik tal you
might probably uh consider a move like
E6 first and then after Queen captures
then Rook to E1 but after Queen to D7
it's not easy to figure out how to
continue this probably you go after the
F Pawn and uh you're still going to win
this game but it's uh much cleaner to
play Rook to E1 first and now you're
threatening E6 so King to E6 was played
stopping E6 and now Rook to G3 and still
uh how do you how do you play this if
you play Rook 8 to G8 which is sort of
the cleanest way to play this you still
face Rook captures Rook captures Queen
H6 check and after King D7 E6 check so
doesn't look all that impressive King to
C8 The Rook will go after the f five
pawn it will be very very hard to defend
but in the game after Rook to G3 Queen
to F7 was played but now the position is
completely winning for Michael uh so
feel free to pause the video and try to
find the winning idea here while I give
you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on always
looking for the weak spot in Black's
camp in pretty much every game and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is Pawn to B4 that's right
that's how you do it and the reason for
this move is that you want to uh before
Pawn to B4 you cannot play Queen to B4
if you gain the B4 uh Square for the
queen then your position will be winning
you will be going after B7 you will be
going after D6 and there will be no
stopping you so B4 is the way to do it
and of course if a captures just Queen
captures you've achieved all of your
goals so here H4 was played attacking
The Rook Rook Rook to B3 and now Pawn to
F4 trying to get some sort of an attack
going against the white king but now
just B captures on A5 winning the B4
Square for the White Queen is crucial
here Rook a to G8 and now Queen to B4
and now how to continue that's the
question do you stop Queen to D6 if so
how to do it if you play Queen to D7 yes
you seem to be stopping this but then
you give up the F4 pawn and then if Rook
to f f you will face Queen to G4 check
and after King to E7 E6 attacking the
queen so you have to guard this Pawn H
but even after Queen to C8 you still
play Rook captures and B7 with check
because you will win the black queen at
the end of this line Queen G7 checking
will move you will capture the pawn and
that's um all there is to it so after
this queen to B4 move Rook to H7 was
played adding a Defender to the B7 Pawn
while also uh not worrying about the D6
square but you cannot uh help uh you
know your king whatever you play Queen
to D6 check King to F5 and now again
Rook captures on B7 winning the F6
Square now for the White Queen Queen
captures on B7 and now Queen to F6 with
check this will not win The Rook on G8
so King has to go to G4 now Queen to E6
check nicely connects with the Rook on
G8 King to H5 Queen captur on G8 and now
Rook to G7 now you're just down two
pawns so even just trading down would be
winning for you uh but you could also
try and Checkmate the black king queen
to f8 was played now comes D4 trying to
open up this diagonal to maybe checkmate
to White King but now Pawn to E6 we have
Pawn to C5 there's mate in one now if
you don't play something really awesome
and well you could go for a king H with
Rook to E5 check just Queen captures on
G7 sacrificing the queen and he was in
this position un move 37 that MOS Bartel
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here point is that you
are now down a full rook and if you take
the queen there is no defense against E7
next move you are queening your pawn and
that's it even if you try something like
let's say Pawn to H3 or Pawn to F3 you
want to Checkmate um the king here uh E8
comes with check that's the problem so
once you move of course uh you will do
pretty much anything like let's say go
King to G4 F3 check and if King to H4
then you play Pawn to G4 you solve all
of your problems let's say F captures
you will play Queen to E4 with check and
only once the king moves let's say queen
G4 check King someware and now you go
after the kill Rook to E6 with check
King H7 Queen to H5 check King to G8
Rook to E8 check now you have to block
and that's it Queen to G6 with checking
h8 Rook captures on f8 will be Checkmate
is only one of the ways how you can end
this uh but yeah after Rook cap Queen
captures Rook on G7 mat said all right I
I resign here uh brilliantly played Mr
Michael Adams uh so yeah that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it Michael and GES
leading the tournament after three
rounds uh both with two wins and one
draw and yeah we'll see we'll see what
happens in the tournament but also what
happens with the Fay candidate spot as
this tournament is one of the five
remaining in the Fay circuit uh the
others being the gashimov memorial the
uh the sanway sies tournament and the
world rapid and Blitz Championship
that's all happening in December and
we'll see if gkes wins this one I think
that he overtakes everyone uh in in the
F circuit and he will be granted a spot
in the FID candidates tournament
although uh although I'm not completely
sure on that so you know with uh each
round I will be more and I will keep you
guys informed H so that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it I would like to
thank David gasparian then Schwarz keep
up the rapid Robert fental and sigurjon
willamson for contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up of uh your
wonderful suggestions whatever else
happens in the Chess World and of course
continuing the London chess classic uh
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day do
check out the gcash game in the previous
video If you still haven't see you soon